pese a los anuncios del final de su vida
útil la misión de la estación espacial
internacional ha sido extendida hasta
2030 fecha límite de certificación de
sus componentes más antiguos y ya ser
tan hay ciertos módulos que quedarán
obsoletos en 10 años entonces la
obsolescencia es técnica y hay
soluciones técnicas de surf o el
reemplazo de elementos o módulos
completos así que es una posibilidad y
allí podemos comenzar de nuevo durante
10 años
ahora la prioridad es mantener la
estación a flote y no es casualidad que
los astronautas pasen la mitad de su
tiempo a bordo preservando su hábitat y
ya comenzaron a aparecer fugas una de
ellas descubierta gracias a una bolsita
de té que fue sellada con cinta adhesiva
los críticos dicen que la estación
espacial internacional es demasiado cara
ya se han gastado unos 150.000 millones
de dólares dicen que es arcaica y que el
mensaje original de reconciliación entre
occidente y rusia perdió vigencia pero
deshacerse de ella no es tan fácil no se
sabe cómo hacerlo para desintegrar la la
atmósfera como la estación mir en el
pasado habría que desmantelar la en el
espacio y multiplicar los viajes de ida
y vuelta pero nadie tiene un presupuesto
u otras soluciones dividir la estación
en varias partes y reutilizar las o
venderlas al sector privado
satán voy y la fuga algunos módulos
podrían separarse y usarse nuevamente
para hacer una estación más pequeña así
que los estadounidenses están pensando
en impulsar el sector privado en ese
país para hacer quizás una dos o incluso
tres estaciones más pequeñas
por el momento el camino elegido es la
continuidad los elementos al final de su
vida útil serán reemplazados a medida
que sea necesario y la base espacial
continuará sirviendo como laboratorio
para aprender todo lo que podamos sobre
la vida en gravedad cero y para
prepararnos para futuros viajes a marte